what is up guys my name is Jonah and
welcome to episode 20 of 3d game
programming in Java episode 20 that's
huge that's pretty bigger okay it's not
that big but episode 20 okay it's not
actually the 20th episode because there
was like nineteen point five eighteen
point five but it's like twenty main
episodes which is awesome - nice
milestone and unfortunately well
fortunately for you guys I guess there's
gonna be like at least like 80 more
episodes cuz when Norway near done like
look at this this is like the beginning
of an engine so um those of you guys
worried that there's only gonna be like
30 episodes yeah that's not the case so
unfortunately for me cuz well it still
take a lot this does take a lot of time
to make but hey it's it's fun that's
actually what that's why I started it
anyway the point is last time we left
off on a bit of like a what do you call
like a climax right the series reached a
climax where suddenly there was a crash
and I didn't solve it and the reason I
didn't solve it straight away was
because you know I wanted to give you
guys a chance to actually solve
something for yourselves because I'll
talk about that a bit in the future but
for now I just want to say you know that
if I do something you know that doesn't
work or doesn't work like like how you
want it to don't be afraid to mess
around with the code and try and try and
figure something out to make it work
because like guys you should be you
should be experimenting with this like I
know a lot of you guys are asking me to
make menus you're asking me to fix like
the mouse rotation they're jumping I've
left that stuff unfixed for a reason
because I want you guys to work out how
to fix it by yourself because there's
nothing more satisfying okay well there
is probably something more satisfying
but there's not many things on this
planet are more satisfying than working
out an error in your code or something
or a bug in your code and fixing it
because that is it's just so satisfying
when you actually work something out for
yourselves so please have a go at doing
that anyway the point is we had a crash
and I unfortunately I am going to have
to fix this because it makes our game
crash and it's not acceptable but you
can see that we get an array index out
of bounds exception now before I
actually fix this
the first thing I want to do is show you
guys how you can basically stop the game
from crashing because what happens is it
just crashes it's like not doesn't rain
excited bounds exception something's
wrong let's let's close the game quick
let's terminate it no all right we don't
want to do that all right what we want
to do is say okay well there's an
exception who cares let's just keep
going like okay there's a small error in
the code doesn't matter don't crash just
keep keep rolling with it and that's
pretty easy now when we run the code
when we debug it you can see that what
happens is it highlights this line for
us because it says well the array index
out of bounds exception is happening
right over here it's happening on line
126 somewhere here and this is alright
so what we can do is we can say let's
try and do this right and we've done
this once before let me just grab this
card and put it in between the brackets
we've done this one before in the
texture class where we actually tried to
load the image and if it didn't work you
know let's just basically catch the
exception so it's basically the same
thing here so we want to try and
basically do these pixels and if it
doesn't work let's catch our array index
out of bounds exception and we're going
to give it a name let's call it eight
because that's just a convention that's
what you do and one thing I want to do
first of all is actually print the sack
trace and what battle that'll do is
actually print out where where we went
wrong in the console which you'll see in
a minute
and finally we actually want to continue
you know screw it let's just keep going
so let's let's try and run this now okay
so this time you can see our game didn't
crash instead is printed a bunch of
stuff in the console and it's still
running okay Andy cuz if that stays in
place perfectly as well so what we've
done essentially let's just close it
right here
what we've done is it's printed all
these like all these numbers that are
out of bounds and it's told us that we
were one an error but it hasn't crashed
the game and that's that's really cool
so for those of you go for those of you
who didn't know that who
still like learning Java or maybe even
learning Java directly off me and only
off me if you don't know try and catch
it's one of the most useful things while
you develop while while you're debugging
your actual code okay this is not a
solution this is really important to
understand that right there is not the
solution to the problem if we get rid of
EEP dot print stack trace there won't
even be much lag because it's taking a
bit of time to render so there's a bit
of lag right there that's all it just
spikes literally like it doesn't it
doesn't crash or anything you can say
that it's fine but this is not the
solution like this is just temporary if
we want to work on something else or you
know we've been working with we've been
trying to fix this error for like five
hours and we haven't gotten anywhere and
we don't want to keep doing it because
we're bored of trying to fix that one
error you can just throw in a quick try
and cash it's like a temporary solution
a quick fix and then come back to it you
know tomorrow or something our fresh
head once you've got some sleep so
that's sort of where you would use try
and catch obviously for some things like
loading files as it's a pair of yeah
they actually have to do it because
files aren't always there for you to use
but for something like this like this is
not the solution okay this is a quick
fix so knowing that the solution is very
simple and it's kind of my fault okay
when I wrote this code I was really
tired so what I did is I actually you go
has probably noticed this I think I saw
one of the comments telling you know you
guys how to fix this basically I've used
top in twice obviously this is a problem
and it shouldn't be top end because it
should be I can explain it but it should
be bottom in all right so we've got you
know if the top is greater is less than
zero then set it equal to zero if the
bottom of the screen is less than the
hottest range that bottom of the screen
is less than 800 well you know set it
equal to 800 so that this should be
bottom an and that's a LC fix so it's
not gonna actually burn anything but you
can see that now it was oh no it doesn't
actually hang hang on all right let's
Garrity's try and catch
okay all right let's check it out
oh wow it is still done that is weird I
thought that was the fix all right I'm
gonna have to investigate this a bit
further all right
oh yeah yeah that's right the other the
other problem is that this isn't int so
you can say that it's well what's
happening is as this wall goes out this
side sort of comes back comes by this
side because um well the reason it does
that is because this is a double it's
not this is a double
it's not it's on this I'm sorry this is
a double it's it's not an integer so
hang on where I might know sir okay
third take this is a double okay it's
not an integer and it needs to be an
integer because width is an integer if
it's only integer errors like that
happen so if we type an end here so if X
pixel right in is greater than width
experts all right N equals width and we
get debug this should work okay it did
all right now before I go ahead and
continue with the rest of this tutorial
I want to point out one thing now if you
notice this isn't current like if you if
you watch this closely it looks like
it's well it's not exactly perfectly
still it looks like it's not exactly
there and the reason for that is it's
did how do I say this the position of
this is an integer at the moment and I
actually left this for you guys as well
but I don't think anyone picked up
picked up on that this is a double and
it's got a cast of an INT in front of it
okay so what's happening is it's
becoming an int so this might as well be
int here it's becoming an integer so
this if we actually just print this real
quick real quick system dot out dot
print line this you can see all we'll
get is
that should be enough 300 point zero
it's not a double and the reason that
that's the problem is that let's just
remove all these costs to answer
integers because we want to be a double
it's obviously integers aren't as exact
as doubles you'll see how much more
exact the double is once we once we
bring it back in
okay so let's save this and let's roll
this okay hang on
are we doubles all right never mind hang
on all right okay well you you can see
visually that it's it it's okay you
might not be able to see it on my screen
but if you remove int from here you'll
see that it looks a lot nicer because
it's like the location of it is a lot
more exact okay so that's that's not a
quick fix thing all right so having that
aside let's move on with the rest of the
tutorial okay a few things I want to I
want to mention real quick the reason
this is coming out this Sunday and not
last Sunday was because I actually went
on a holiday for a week so I left like
last Friday and I can't and I came back
yesterday which is which was Friday okay
I'm recording this on Saturday instead
of Sunday today cuz I actually want to
have this episode ready to release on
Sunday because I think last time I ended
up like not being able to make it in
time and I had to release in Monday
morning and a lot of you guys were angry
all right we weren't angry bit I was
kind of angry with myself so that's why
I that's why I'm recording this one de
la bete anyway point is I got back from
a holiday was awesome and that's why
this episode is one week late okay the
other thing is what are we gonna be
doing this this tutorial because
obviously what we've done right now is
about fixing we haven't we haven't
actually added anything anything else so
the first thing I want to do is sort of
get ready for textures okay so at the
moment we're we're not really really
ready to accept textures onto this yet
we need to make sure that this conforms
to our 8x8 texture at the moment I'll
talk about about high resolution
textures in a later episode it's a lot
easier to have like low resolution
textures like 8 by 8 because 8 is such
an awesome number so we'll talk about
later but like maybe episode I don't
know 40 or something will be
high-resolution textures but at the
moment we've got an 8x8 texture going
here so we're gonna use the same like
8x8 resolution on this so we have to
actually like prepare this basically to
accept a texture onto it and I'll talk
about that in a minute and the other
thing is moving okay a lot of you guys
have said that when I move this thing
moves ridiculously fast how do I fix it
alright well you should be able to work
this out yourself but I'll show you guys
how to do it this episode as well so
that's it I think I think this is the
first time I'm actually announced what
we're actually gonna do in this episode
but uh I don't know this is that this is
gonna be like a huge episode there's a
lot of code to type there's a lot of
calculations to work out which is why I
actually spent like most of the day
working it out so I've got a massive
like a list in front of me basically
with all the code and I'll be I'll be
copying off that mainly so if this takes
a while or something then just you know
I'm sorry but this card has to be has to
be done and I currently memorize it cuz
there's just there's so much
calculations you'll see but uh yeah so
let's get started first thing I want to
talk about is um is the texture and
render distance actually that's another
thing if you are if you check this out
let's just um go over here open our
screen close which is not here there it
is
okay actually what's that wasn't it and
say it anyway so our screen closed if we
grab I think that's the distance isn't
it as that distance yeah okay if we grab
this and put like five or even better
like 18 then it's still not it's still
like it's like okay you can see that
it's not it's not any darker even though
it should be fairly dark and if you're
saying oh that's just because raina
distance limiter is here if we put it
here that's not gonna change anything
I've picked ctrl s I've saved it I can't
even save anymore it's it's still there
and also this is important I got
interested this for fun make sure right
now go onto your screen class and make
sure that your render wall is before
render distance limiter
so that it actually renders the fog the
render distance on top of the wall so
that the wall is affected by it
otherwise the wall will be in front it's
like a layer and After Effects or
Photoshop or whatever program you use
it's like a layer that's in front of the
other layer so if if the wall is in
front of the render distance limiter
it's obviously gonna be in front of it
and you won't actually see the wall get
affected by it so that's really
important make sure read render distance
limiter is after around the wall also
I'm sorry I'm talking so fast I just
there's so much - there's so much do I
probably should have split us up at it
into two tutorials but I know you guys
really like long boring tutorials so hey
I figured this is me making up not being
here last week okay anyway so let's get
started into this whole thing so but the
first thing I want to do before we
actually get onto like movement and
stuff is the render distance and the
textures so let's when I okay
to reiterate we're not going to be
applying textures to this today okay but
what we are going to be doing is
preparing it to accept texture so
basically what we want to do is could
form it to an 8x8 grid this thing so
that's what we're gonna do today as well
as render distance and then when we want
to move in any way let's say enough
talking about what we're actually gonna
do it let's actually do it so let's go
let's go to UM this our end up free
class and um and get started okay so
there's a few few different things I
want to fix up the first of them is I
want to set up like a whole text shift
basis thing that's that gets sort of
affected by ah by a bunch of stuff by
rotation so that the textures don't do
stall when we rotate it stuff like that
let's let's check that out
okay so the first thing we want to do is
let's go I was just like eh let's put it
right after our four corner pins let's
let's make
we'll make four variables text is non
santhu texture I'm going to call it one
so we need four because there's four
corners but not really like this we just
need four variables to handle the
different rotations and some of that so
the first thing I'm gonna do is to go 1
divided by our left side C or Z rotation
and obviously we have to do the same
thing for the right side rotation 1
divided by right side said oops I called
it traditionally actually you would
probably go text 0 text 1 but I'm just
going to go 1 & 2
probably you guys will probably
understand better and 3 will be 0
divided by our left side Zed and finally
the 4 it's gonna be 16 yeah we'll call
it 8 for now I'm not sure if this is
exact will say rotation right beside Zed
and we'll actually subtract text 3 from
it because we'll have to do that later
anyway so we might as well do it right
in variable all right sir
right over here all created I'll create
a double call it X texture so X texture
is going to be like the horizontal
texture of it and we'll make another one
called white texture later on later on
which will be there the vertical texture
of it so let's set that that's first of
all cast that into an end we'll make it
an end because obviously textures can't
be doubles so mm okay int X texture so
we'll go text 3 + text four times our of
this obvious pixel rotation and we
actually need to divide it by text 1 & 2
and pixel rotation ok I'm gonna create a
damn it
okay I'll call it I'll just I'll call it
X text
I just okay mmm should I know I'm not
going to do that swear that I'm just
gonna type it out here I was going to
put it into another variable but I think
that it might be if I don't like this
and we'll divide this by text 1 + text 2
- text 1 and times it by our pixel
rotation all right sorry that's
basically our texture handler right
there and that's looking good let's
actually let's put it into perspective
right here okay
let's debug it right now so we can
actually see what's going on as I change
it and let's set this back to like 1.5
or something so we can actually see it
wonderful alright so instead of instead
of this wonderful color being here and
that is good color I'm gonna have to
write that down what are the 0 X 1 b9 1
a 0 is the color okay guys remember
that's fantastic color I picked it out
myself
it's awesome anyway um we're actually
gonna change it to like a pattern sort
of so let's just go ahead and go X
texture which is right over here so that
gives us ok black let's multiply it by
whoop 1 - that's the right thing to
multiply by nope
okay let's run it yeah okay so we're
getting like a gradient here you can see
lets go 100 or is better there's a bit
of motion going on but don't worry we'll
fix that in a bit
okay so we've basically we've basically
and I quote again basically got our
horizontal section worked out you can
see that it's still sort of being
affected by rotation so it's not it's
not perfect but we're gonna ignore that
for now and actually create a white
texture as well so we've got that we've
got as you can see we've got horizontals
now and by it they look vertical but
they're actually like they're horizontal
so it's like one two three four five
it's going that way right so now to make
this like a grid we need a vertical as
well and that's pretty simple to make
let's first of all
make a pixel rotation fool for the wise
so we've got our pixel rotation just
like the X stuff you can see it's X
minus X Box the left Xbox all right now
we basically need to do the same thing
before why and and you might be asking
why get it why why but uh well as bad it
wasn't I'm sorry but the reason why is
because obviously you need a handle
rotation that's you need a handle
rotation on two fronts top and bottom on
top and bottom like top and right or
whatever you want to call it basically
horizontal and vertical X&Y you always
have to handle X&Y so we've done X now
doing Y look we did a for loop for X
right here we've got a full look for y
we've done rotation for X we need to do
a rotation for y we've done texture X we
need to do texture for why it's you get
used to it okay you need to do stuff for
X&Y
basically when you're doing graphics
programming any grab I'm not talking
about games I'm just talking about
graphics programming in general and I'm
talking so fast I'm gonna take a drink
oh yeah what what is good um okay right
so why we did X minus X Box to left now
let's do y minus y pixel now it's not
left all right it's actually top okay
because top is like the equivalent of
left except on the Y plane and it will
divide that by X picked like I'm
essentially copying off this so what is
okay so left is taught what's right
bottom X pixel bottom minus X pixel top
top top and that's it
and we crashed why did we crash on deck
special table whoops my bad
what just happened I just somehow to lay
to that line we had okay back to this so
we've done that let's make some room
here actually can't really say much and
actually wanted to make this an int
because this has to be in it and now we
can do Y texture and we'll set that
equal to
obviously cast int and we'll go
we'll just go eight times not the other
way around
eight times our pixel rotation why I
can't be bothered typing it out so I'm
just gonna copy and paste it
all right so let's save that okay we're
done awesome we've done that now let's
actually just add in why texture and
multiply that by 100 so that gives us
and check that out
we've got an awesome pattern the colors
kind of suck so I'm just gonna multiply
the whole thing by like 256 because a
multiple of two yeah awesome okay so we
basically essentially got a grid problem
though it's like it's basically
stretching when we rotate it which
obviously isn't the desired effect so we
need to fix that that's actually hang on
I think 16 was better sixteen sixteen
two minutes okay actually that's good
we've actually got two conforming to an
8x8 which is good again I'm surprised
that worked because in my calculations I
had to eat 16 but yeah actually while
we're at it this let's let's change all
this a two-burner this shouldn't affect
this but uh well this should be two
people I know I just realized that'll
make it much more smooth an exact
okay so we've dodged another bullet
there all right okay so we've basically
got a thing it's still it's still like
you can see that it's still it's not
rotating correctly but that's fine okay
we'll ignore that for now and we'll
actually come back to that in a bit but
first things first I actually want to UM
I want to talk on render distance
limiting now and that's pretty easy to
do okay we've got our Zed buffer here
right and what we need to do is
basically go 1 divided by where's our
okay yeah I should have created a
variable shouldn't I've damn it okay
okay well it's out
all right where's that texture there it
is
but this so one divided by let's put
this in brackets 1 divided by that times
16 16 can be changed actually let's just
make it 2 for now no we'll make it 16
and I think I've got one extra bracket
or something right okay I'll save it
okay so you can see that it's darkened
the whole thing and you can actually
play around with this number again you
could set this to like two or you could
set this to like 100 and you can see
it's completely blocked because it's
that far away actually it's not
completely black you can actually see a
bit 1001 we can complete completely
black but yeah you can play around with
this I think 16 is fairly good since
they might be too much on my role with
12 for now but that's basically as dark
as you want this to go and if you go to
screen and you actually this should
actually no hang on this should be
pretty bright because this is basically
as close as you get let's try eight and
be like four I don't know it's good
let's set it tight
if you go over here and Chuck this down
to like five you'll see oh look at that
it's darker 10 look at that you can
barely see it at all like it that's
that's right a distance limiting fixed
and done up right there so that's that's
awesome
all right one is right up at the camera
and yeah it's awesome
all right so we've essentially done some
done some good work here we've got a
small bug and that is this rotation
stuff which I should probably fix right
now once I figure out the problem that
is okay so it's obviously a problem with
the texture somewhere because the only
thing that's actually doing that is it
texture or it could be a problem with
rotation as well I'm not sure but it's
rotation and texture is being affected
this is another good thing for you guys
to diagnose stuff I just look at it like
if you look at it you can say that
what's being affected here is up and
down screwing up no no it looks like a
rotation
and the actual texture is being affected
so the texture is being affected by
rotation in a way that it's not supposed
to be affected by rotation so
something's wrong with rotation and the
texture or more precisely probably
rotation and/or texture is being
affected so there's something wrong with
that so let's work that out okay
I'm just gonna close this go fullscreen
and let's dig into this code and check
out what's wrong
alright so keeping in mind that it's
pixel and rotate texture and rotation
I'm pretty sure our rotation is fine
because otherwise our actual box thing
would be scrolling up rather than the
actual texture so I want to say it's the
textures fault so let's go ahead and
check out texture constant oh wow
obviously okay I'm an idiot okay so
we've got a bracket here in a bracket
here you can say but we don't have a
bracket here okay and what's what's what
it's actually doing is it's dividing
this by this and then it's adding this
so obviously math in mathematics you
know Bob math bomb - whatever you wanna
call it
um the brackets come first
denis multiplication and division and
then it's addition so it divides this it
divides this bracket what what it
divides everything in the bracket by
text 1 and then it adds on text 2 and
then it adds on that so we actually
wanted to add this stuff first
let's put brackets here and then divide
this by this alright important make sure
you do that this should work look at
that it works ok let's actually open up
all this so I can actually see
everything ok
so noting that we can fairly be fairly
sure that if you count these squares and
it's incredibly hard to do so while this
thing is rotating so let's go ahead and
actually just shut off rotation where's
rotation here it is that's some
I'm just gonna comment that out and set
us to zero okay so we've got 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 by 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
perfect we've got 8 by 8 it's ready for
the actual texture so we've we've
accomplished that we have accomplished
our render distance oh wow what did I
just do big mistake okay
that was one when I was little water
main 0.5 okay yeah don't touch that what
I did there is I actually extended the
wall as you can see it's gonna be 2
units if I do that now and the problem
with that is the texture gets stretched
so in future if you want to walls what
you want to have to do is duplicate this
and set this to be 1 and 0.5 so now
we've got two walls and as you can see
there's 16 across now so that's
important obviously there'll be a better
way to actually place down walls then
then you use this and we'll work on that
a bit later on but now we've got a basic
way to actually use walls and it seems
to be working for us okay so we've got
that let's talk about building stuff
like what about walls that go this way
right
what about walls that go towards the
camera how do we how do we do that very
simply okay now the first thing we
actually need to do is go into our
render class let's shut this off for a
bit and let's make one more variable
here let's call it Z distance what is it
right and we'll call this one set as
that distance left right so let's
problem with this we forgot the comma so
we got this and let's replace that with
that so left will be the top one so the
left will be left and right will be
right so what will happen now is we have
to go to square and actually adjust it
but basically what that just did is we
set that birth to 1.5 it won't actually
changed anything or it shouldn't change
anything again I know I'm talking fast
but I just have to get through this all
right
it's 8:00 p.m. I promised my friend I'd
play cod with them at this time
so sacrificing anyway point is he can
wait
point is yeah we've got like the right
side Zed so if we said it's like 15 you
can okay if your fins a bit of a stretch
maybe like five you can save and like
three you can say that it's like it's
doing that and if we set this to three
it's like the left one right so um and
the other the other awesome thing is you
can see if that's broader than that so
the render distance is working even
though even though it's just like the
same object which is awesome okay anyway
the point is we've got this now how do
we use it let's set this back to 1.5 as
it was let's duplicate this and copy and
paste it and let's actually okay I have
to think for a bit because this could be
hard to figure out so I always have to
put my mouse over this so I can actually
see the variable name so I can see which
parameter is which so that's the left
that's the right way at the both zero
double as their distance left should be
1.5 and the right this should be one
just feet 1.5 okay so one is done and
you can actually see it right now is if
I if I back up a bit you can see that
it's created a wall like that like how
cool is that it's awesome the problem is
that we can't like okay the reason we
can't say it here first of all is
obviously we're rotating around in front
of it and it is a 2d object so it it
doesn't have any depth so it's you know
it's like if you if you look at a 2d
object exactly on the side it's
invisible okay that's why I obviously 2d
objects don't exist in life and no paper
is not 2d okay paper has a very small
depth but it has a depth I'm pretty sure
you guys know that I don't think anyone
in this world actually thinks the paper
is 2d I don't know why I said that but
the point is this is 2d okay
that's why we can't see it if we back up
a bit and here we go you can see that
this is you know it's created that and
it's there so that's awesome okay now
the problem here is movement right now
so let's pick some movement and then
we'll then we'll get back to this okay
so movement this the difficulty level of
fixing this is probably about 3 out of
like it's really simple okay all you
have to do is say okay actually it'll
screw this let's go up to the top first
of all and maximize this and shut off
our rotation so we'll go back to our
mouse for rotation and let's check it
out
okay so mouse rotation is working
awesome
and you you guys should get back to
fixing it because I'm not gonna fix it
for you for a while I probably fixed it
near the end of the game but at the
moment you know make it loop and make it
make it go different speeds okay I match
I might show you guys how to make a go
different speeds because that might be
hard but looping the screen is really
easy you guys should be able to work it
out also if someone does on behalf of
the community work this out for you guys
I will give them a shout out okay so if
you know post a comment and whoever post
a comment first will get a shout out
because uh yeah you guys should be able
to fix this and I hope one of you will
and if one of you does then I'll reward
them okay anyway back to this so we've
got this we've got all of our thing you
can see that we can sort of go this way
and we've completely lost our thing now
so let's restart again alright so we've
got this you can see the problem like
you can see the problem it's moving
really fast even if we crash look at
that it goes way down if we jump or if
we you know fly in the air you can see
goes up way too high so how do you fix
that
and the answer is like it's exactly what
you would think you would do okay
let's go to our floor our hole rendering
thing and say okay look at this right is
here actually let's let's fix up and
down first up is here right so obviously
when we when we hit up up and up is
defined about by our game type controls
not why it was defy its defined by the
by user controls so when we hit up
obviously something changes and we can
see that when we hit up this goes weight
this goes up way too high so we need to
somehow decrease this value how does one
do that
I wonder how okay very simple let's
surround it in brackets first of all
let's just multiply it by like zero
point zero point five okay let's just
try zero point five again let's run that
and let's check it out all right
obviously we need to do it for
everything like we've only done it for
this up there's three more ups to deal
with okay you can see that it gets
skewed a bit that's still way too high
so it goes up way too high
actually okay I'm not gonna fool around
because I've already worked this out
this has to be negative up and I'll
check it out now I care cool
that's way too much 0.05 maybe mmm all
right interesting we should probably go
with the bottom left corner actually
let's just copy this so negative up
times 0.05 oh god I keep forgetting
their brackets all right this should be
good yep continue that up again so here
we go when we jump this stays put okay
seems about right I think that's about
right yeah okay that's about right so
let's apply it to the other things okay
so obviously I work this out beforehand
so that I wouldn't have to waste time
here my figuring out because what this
is is it's basically a game of me or the
programmer trying to work out a value
that works okay this is what we're doing
out here so we jump you can see that it
still lifts up off the ground a bit you
can see right there if you look at the
bottom it still sort of flies up a bit
and while playing around with this today
I figured out that the most exact value
I could come up with it's reasonable was
uh where are we 0.06 - okay so 0.06 -
was pretty exact okay and the other
problem is that we have to if we change
this this like correction value we have
to change it everywhere okay so we have
to change the four times
so obviously the smart thing to do would
be to create a variable that would be in
one place so if you change that it
changes that it changes the same thing
four times so now if we jump you can see
that's
I couldn't get a more exact Matt you can
see if that's perfect
it's pretty perfect if you guys get a
number that you think is more perfect
posted in the comments below and you
know might use that if that's better
because um I don't know that's pretty
that's pretty I'm pretty sure that's
perfect I don't know it looks pretty
perfect though
so 0.62 okay so I'm actually gonna gonna
do the small thing here and create some
more variables
it's maximize this so I'll go double
will call this up correct okay because
this is correcting the up this cracking
me up and I'll set it to 0.06 to is that
that's what it was currently alright so
let's let's change that with the
variable name okay so - up times up
correct and let's just test that works
of course it will because we just did it
so we need it and actually the values
0.062 seems to work for everything so I
could just call it correct and apply it
to everything but just to be safe
in case it are in case it like screws up
in the future I'm just gonna create a
right correct
0.06 - a what else is there a forward
correct and and the full correct that's
it and right correct is obviously gonna
be here
so let's surround this with brackets and
multiply it by that and I'm just gonna
copy this entire thing because I don't
have time to play around with this
I can't that's it actually and forward
let's actually name it properly for
would not forward fold correct and let's
obviously surround this with brackets
and multiply that by that and copy that
whole expression and where s is forward
here it is alright
and check that up okay so now when we
were around you can see that whoa look
check this out it stays in the same
place obviously if we go behind it we
can't see it because again it's 2d
object and it's actually inverted okay
it should be the other way around but
we'll talk about that later
now the only problem we see at this
point is that you can see that when we
walk what happens is it our it moves
like it it moves and the reason is that
the floor is moving up and down but it
isn't because when we walk we did this
bobbing thing where are where is it
walking okay so what we need to do now
is compensate for the fact that it Bob's
up and down and that's fairly easy to do
as well all we have to do for that is um
let's get rid of the double here and
let's actually put walking as a global
things so that we can access it there
and all right so we've got our basic
expressions here check this out let's go
deeper Wow Inception anyway okay so
we've got we've got these with others if
so if if we're walking basically it
moves the floor position up and down all
right that's cool let's I don't know why
this is up here let's just grab this
let's cut it and let's put it right over
here I don't know why it was there
that's kind of unorganized of me to put
it there okay so if we're walking we
want about Bob up bob up and down but
the problem is that obviously we want to
compensate for that so uh it's pretty
simple I guess first of all so if we
walk okay simple so walking is currently
set to this all right let's go probably
don't need is here let's delete the uh
naturally and oh hang on before we
delete it let's cut it actually and put
it right over here so that if we
actually do walk closer walking equal to
that and that still works we seem to be
bobbing up and down happily and
especially
okay let's try and find out say the
render distance limiter is well is that
a problem I think that's a problem I
don't know that's kind of weird actually
I shouldn't have happened okay now we
seem to be working fine not sure what
that was
anyway um oh this thing here and this
seems to be working fine so all we have
to do now is okay that's cool
the other problem I think that I might
have fixed without even knowing
no I didn't don't worry you know that
okay let's get back to this so all we
have to do here and if you think about
this what happens is when we walk our
thing bounces up and down right but the
problem is we haven't set that to the
wall so our our floor and ceiling bounce
up and down but our walls don't so why
why is that let's fix up
so let's come in here and whenever we
walk so we're walking around here what
we actually need to do is add on let's
add it right over here plus now walking
okay so that's that's what we need to do
let's let's just actually copy it again
so that so that I don't have to type it
out a million times
let's put it after our corrects and this
should work
we don't need for up correct we're gonna
for left only we only need it for our
you know up for our sorry for our
forward right that's it I think okay so
let's check that out
oh that did something that probably
shouldn't have
actually that's alright hang on
okay so off-center now and okay oh hang
on no I'm wrong I'm wrong all right yeah
I'm wrong okay you know that sorry I
don't know how from the thing he's right
obviously when we walk we only need to
bounce up and down we don't really
bounce left and right I don't know why I
just completely forgot about that so
this should only affect our office our
ups and downs so in other words our up
so the way we wear we only affect that
is by putting walking only in our up so
only where we have up do we add on
walking okay so so now we have a problem
first of all it seems that again there's
a problem and the problem seems to be
that let's start this is fine is that
it's it's going up and down way too much
so what we need to do is add adding that
correct thing so i'll make a new
variable call a double walk correct and
we'll set it equal to zero point zero
six two I don't know that's the magic
number I'm actually gonna start loving
that number from now on because zero
point zero six to six plus two is eight
which is a number two seems to be
following me around my street numbers
eight everything I pretty much get is
eight I'm not shirking like my locker
number is eight it's ridiculous
everything's eight anyway point is it's
a good number zero point zero six two is
a fantastic number so walk correct let's
simply multiply it that by walk erect
walk correct and we should be chilling
here we should be which would be good
okay sorry okay one thing there's a
problem here apart from the fact that
our 0.062 number doesn't seem to be
working correctly oh hang on my bad
it should be negative zero point zero
six tear there we go you can see that's
perfect now
okay problem when we crouch only when we
craft when we jump it doesn't happen
when we crouch it does it okay for some
reason it it assumes that we're walking
if we're crouched which isn't good
because we're not walking which is still
in my crash but the walls seem to been
seem to be bouncing up and down easily
fixed let's come up here into our
walking and say if Crouch walk and if
we're actually walking so what does it
walk do you only do that so now that we
Crouch look at that it doesn't do it
anymore and it actually doesn't do when
we jump which is good okay when we hit
shift it doesn't so again let's come
into control run walk control don't roam
walk and I'm an add-on and don't know
why I pasted them and controller dot
walk so now I hit shift nothing happens
now we do that that does work it's
actually a bit dodgy it's weird
hmm
can't we it isn't it it's not perfect
because it seems to stop it doesn't seem
to reset a positioning yeah then it's
weird anyway we're not gonna fix that
now because can't be bothered
okay but the met for the main part it
seems to work we've done basically
everything over here works let's back
away and you can see that the render
distance works perfectly again if you
think that it's too dark being that far
out you could just go in here and go on
here where are we here yeah and and
actually change 8 to like I don't know 4
and that'll make you brighter as you can
see if you think it's too bright you can
change it to 16 but I think it is pretty
good actually I don't know maybe like
because fools
yeah cuz look that's way too bright yeah
it should be a lot yeah I'm gonna say it
is perfect actually
okay yeah it freezes it it seems it
doesn't reset it that's weird though it
should okay hang on I'm gonna fix this
right now cuz it's bothering me okay
what do we go with our rotation so
walking is this we're now walking up
there and I get school okay first of all
actually because we've removed it let's
add this into every single one that
should help with the with the general
look at the game and the other thing is
because those those used to be above it
and now they're below it that's why
that's that's why it's a problem because
these two if statements used to be above
the kid to walk statement but now we've
we've sort of changed change their
location which is why I had to add that
in to compensate for it hmm well it's
actually yeah that's probably the reason
actually okay so the problem is that mmm
I don't know what the problem is
okay hang on so let's let's just this is
some life fixing for you guys let's
actually print our walking along without
actually very actual variable in our
console sort of zero oh yeah that's
obviously a problem all right so if you
look at this if we walk and then we stop
it actually it just stops it doesn't but
it okay yeah okay easily easy okay so
we've got a problem we can see it what
happens is when we stop walking it
doesn't it doesn't set the location of
the floor and ceiling in the walls back
to zero just stays it just leaves it up
at whatever point we finish we happen to
finish walking as you can see that
happened to be zero point seven nine
nine
zero zero six nine seven four nine zero
four four two okay we need to set that
number back to zero so that's pretty
simple we should just go up here and go
walking equals zero and I just deliver
that line somehow I don't even know how
I keep deleting like entire lines of
code but anyway so what that did is
basically say if if it's this if if
control walk set it equal to this if
it's not just reset it back to zero and
this should work yeah you can see that
right over here so when we walk it does
it you can see that crazy thing and now
stop your zero zero zero okay so that's
awesome let's go let's go over here and
you can see that now tray this out it
works it looks perfect it's awesome
okay so now that we've completely owned
it movement let's actually do play this
two more times and let's attempt to I
think a car key for getting those so the
Z distance it's the third and fourth
okay so let's set these two there 1.5
here let's just set them to one and
we'll set this to 0.5 so we'll get that
wall we got that wall and then we'll set
these both of these to 0.5 to get that
wall okay no that didn't work I'll hang
on because that should be obviously that
should be point five there we go
okay so now we've got an awesome and you
can see inside it cube let's just line
inside it whoa look at that that's
awesome alright we've got this
okay we've got okay so we've got this
awesome like cube-like thing now it's
awesome okay but we've got a problem
right now and the problem here is that
it's completely invisible when we look
at it from this side why okay simple
it's a simple okay actually before we
get into that let's quickly remove this
damn walking thing okay the reason the
short reason why is because it's it's
like a graphical thing if there's no
data assigned to that edge it's not
there so we've got no data on that side
we've we're only showing that texture on
one side okay that's the problem I'm not
gonna fix it for you guys right now I'm
gonna give you guys homework yep that's
right some guy wrote in the comments I
thought it was a good idea sorry I
scratched that several guys wrote in the
comments I thought it was an actual idea
and yeah so your homework for today and
I really feel like a teacher saying this
figure out why you can't look at it from
this side and figure out how you can
look at textures from 360 degrees and
they won't disappear okay that's your
homework hint it's something to do with
inverting textures and with inverting
the normals so inverting the side of the
thing that's your hint have fun
whoever solves it first and either
tweets it at me or leaves it in the
comments preferably preferable as
comments that's my preferred area we'll
get a shout out as standard and and yeah
and I will obviously implement that next
time so yep I want you guys to work out
something for yourselves
I fixed movement for you guys this was
really easy to face as you can see and
it looks awesome we've got walls now
they rotate perfectly we can look at
them from three it's it's obviously 3d
right there and yeah so that's what
we've done today
one more thing episode 21 we're just
gonna come out next Sunday again I'm
doing this again because it really does
help me out like the video guys because
episode 21 will only come out when this
video hits one
hundred likes okay we hit it in like 12
hours last time so let's do it let's do
that again okay
hit the like button let's get this - we
should probably be able to get this 200
by now I've got like 1,200 subscribers
but anyway the point is 100 likes and
episode 21 will be released on Sunday
that's it okay
simple as that one more thing before I
go okay follow me on Twitter
okay a lot of people don't even know I
have a Twitter I do have a Twitter
account its twitter.com four slash the
chair know okay
I'll the link is in the description and
on the screen right now if I remember to
put it in I probably will do so Twitter
calm for slash the channel that's where
you follow me on Twitter okay if you
want to know when I live stream if you
want to know what's rolling what the
status of the next episode is how it's
coming along what's gonna be in it stuff
like that basically or basically what's
going on going on in my life I tweet a
lot so Twitter is the best place to
contact me as well you can tweet at me
and basically know what's up with me and
it's pretty simple the other thing is
Facebook okay III do have a Facebook
page I don't really like Facebook pages
as much as Twitter which is why I do
prefer Twitter but um yeah so I but the
links to my Twitter and Facebook are in
the description of this video
okay I know that a lot of you guys
sometimes miss live streams and you're
really upset because the video that
announces that I am live stream that I
am live streaming doesn't publish
properly and stuff like that that's why
you follow me on Twitter because Twitter
tweets tweets happen to publish properly
which is good unlike videos on YouTube
so best place to fall to find out what's
up is Twitter so yeah anyway guys later
100 likes don't forget to like the video
anyway see you later and don't forget
your homework
either okay right